on a les moyens de faire en sorte que
les gens puissent tous les soirs
continuent à regarder TPMP puisse
continuer à tourner ton émission et pour
ça comment on fait comment on fait
d'abord on a fait le plein de stocks de
gaz
100 %. il y a du gaz de fou ensuite on
démarre petit à petit les réacteurs
problème c'est qu'on s'est retrouvé avec
un tiers du parc nucléaire à l'arrêt et
que le nucléaire c'est 60 % de notre
électricité donc quand vous en avez un
tir en rate vous comprenez que ça pose
quelques petits problèmes EDF travail et
d'ailleurs moi je salue les techniciens
aujourd'hui je sois les mécaniciens les
robinettiers les chaudronniers qui
travaillent très dur sur les chantiers
en 3,8 pour faire en sorte que les
maintenances soient faites correctement
dans les temps que les réacteurs donc
ils travaillent comme des membres voilà
exactement il y a aujourd'hui plein de
gens de la filière donc toutes les
secteurs de l'énergie qui bossent pour
que on arrive justement à passer
l'univers convenablement ce que je dis
en revanche c'est que il est possible
qu'il y a des moments de tension et
pendant les moments de tension on va
demander ce que je disais avant aux
entreprises aux administration et en
dernier lieu aux Français de faire des
efforts est-ce que les Français on
pourrait les vite on pourra l'éviter ou
pas mais les Français on pourra les
visiter c'est pour ça qu'on demande
d'abord on va demander le max aux
entreprises et aux administrations et
notamment aux grosses entreprises celles
qui consomment beaucoup
de réduire leur consommation pour qu'on
n'est pas à demander des efforts aux
Français on a demandé beaucoup d'efforts
aux Français ces dernières années sur le
covid
et donc vraiment l'idée c'est de
préserver autant que possible et de
protéger les gens parce que janvier là
après Noël déjà tu as plus d'oser ça
t'arrive en janvier tu es comme un con
il fait des périodes
froid c'est février
puis à faire en janvier en journée tu te
lèves le matin il fait nuit tu te tu te
lèves le soir il fait nuit
une dernière chose qui est importante
c'est qu'en plus on dit faut demander
aux Français de faire des efforts mais
aujourd'hui le prix de l'énergie il est
cher et les gens ils font déjà des
c'est aussi pour ça que je dis que c'est
aux entreprises et aux administrations
de prendre leur part
attention
de Noël tout ça là parce que j'ai
entendu parler est-ce qu'on peut pour
lui demander pardon Hidalgo d'arrêter le
marteau-piqueur alors
proactive volontairement proposer des
plantes sobriété pour faire attention
dans leur ville alors ça veut pas dire
qu'on coupe tout parce que avec
décoration de Noël ça fait aussi plaisir
aux enfants ça consomme pas forcément
énormément pour certaines
par contre je pense que ça suffira pas
pour demander à Anne Hidalgo d'arrêter
les travaux
qui voulez-vous sucer oui
ça commence bien non qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de l'idée de la suggestion de
Sandrine Rousseau qui dit couper
l'électricité dans les aéroports et les
supermarchés
exactement
on a quand même démarré le concours
Lépine de la sobriété donc là on a les
aéroports
c'est 60% de l'électricité qu'on produit
aujourd'hui les écologistes et la France
insoumise ils passent leur temps à nous
dire il faut arrêter de nucléaire et
quand le nucléaire fonctionne pas
suffisamment bien et donc on a des
problèmes sur l'approvisionnement il
râle parce que le nucléaire fonctionne
pas suffisamment bien et ensuite il
demande qu'on arrête les décorations de
Noël et les aéroports voilà il faut être
un peu cohérent un peu de rationalité
tout ça devrait bien se passer il faut
l'avoir au calme et
une application alors en France RTE quel
réseau de transport d'électricité eux
ils sont responsables de faire en sorte
qu'on est bien toujours production
également consommation à tout moment
puisque l'électricité ça se stocke pas
donc on est obligé d'avoir l'équilibre
en permanence Ecowatt c'est une
application que vous pouvez télécharger
sur votre téléphone et qu'on voit ici et
qui va vous dire est-ce que on est dans
un moment de tension ou pas et ça
permettra par exemple si un mardi on est
sur un moment où c'est particulièrement
difficile mais la veille vous aurez une
petite notification en disant voilà
demain éventuellement un peu plus
ça permettra d'alerter les gens
d'alerter les entreprises d'alerter les
services publics et c'est extrêmement
bien fait et d'ailleurs il y a on a
dépassé hier le million de
téléchargements des kowatts ça a doublé
en l'espace de quelques jours ce qui est
bien la preuve que les français ils sont
responsables